what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be taking the 16 personalities test
I've heard a lot about this test I've
probably taken it at some point but
today I'm going to be taking it again
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos guys
our goal is to hit a million subscribers
before New Year's Eve it's a hefty goal
but I think we can do it so make sure
you subscribe to the channel it's so
incredible to finally be understood I'm
going to be understood in 10 minutes you
regularly make new friends I would
actually say when I put time into it I
make friends pretty easy I would say
agree
um but I don't I like do a lot of the
same things so then it's like I just I
tend to hang around the same people you
spend a lot of your free time exploring
various random topics that pique your
intro I mean that's like basically what
this channel is
UM seeing other people cry can easily
make you feel like you want to cry too I
disagree yeah I sympathy isn't always
the best for me
um okay you often make a backup plan for
a backup a backup plan disagree I would
say I don't think a lot of things
through you usually stay calm even under
a lot of pressure I would say slightly
agree for a woman for a woman I would
say for it for a man no before a woman I
would say yes
um at social events you rarely try to
introduce yourself to new people and
mostly talk to the ones you already know
disagree I'm a chit chatter I like to
talk I'm I'm a chit chatter you prefer
to completely finish one project before
starting another uh disagree I start up
many projects
um you are very sentimental I feel like
if I have to ask if I'm sentimental I'm
probably not I'll say disagree
um you like organette no okay I'm not
organized okay even a small mistake can
cause you to doubt your overall
abilities and knowledge
was younger maybe but now not really
because I feel like the older you get
you just kind of know what you're good
at so I'm gonna say disagree you feel
comfortable just walking up to someone
you find interesting and starting a
conversation I am a talker yeah yeah I
feel comfortable you are not too
interested in discussing various
interpretations and Analysis of creative
works yeah it's kind of like what this
channel is right yeah I'll say yes
um you are more inclined to follow your
heart than your head well I'm a woman so
yeah
um you usually prefer doing what you
feel like at any given moment instead of
planning a particular daily routine yeah
like too much I'm not very good at
planning or routines you rarely worry
about what whether you make a good
impression on People You Meet
um when I was younger I did but now it's
just kind of like
uh you can't really help like you can't
you're not in control of how other
people feel so why am I going to spend
that much time like worrying if people
like me when I literally can't control
how you feel you enjoy participating in
group activities yeah I've always been
on teams and stuff I would agree you
like books and movies that make you come
up with your own interpretation of the
ending no I always hated that when they
had like two endings in movies like tell
me what the ending is
um your happiness comes from helping
others accomplish things than your own
accomplishments no I would say no
because I feel like if I did I would
have been coaching by now for sports and
I'm just still a player so you are
interested in so many things that you
find it difficult to choose what to try
next yes that's true I really like a lot
of things you are prone to worrying
about things that will take a turn for
the worse not really I just don't think
a lot of things through you avoid
leadership roles in group settings I
don't like being in charge of people so
I would say yeah you are different
definitely not an artistic type of
person now I'm pretty creative I used to
say no to this question because I don't
actually do like paint or anything but I
would say I'm very creative and I do
like music and stuff you think the world
would be a better place if people relied
more on rationality and lessen their
feelings yeah I strongly agree with that
you prefer to do your chores before
you're allowing yourself to relax no I
don't
you enjoy watching people argue yeah I
like good TV you tend to avoid drawing
attention to yourself I think I that
would be wrong since I have a YouTube
channel
um your mood can change very quickly
that went really I think you guys have
seen I can I stay pretty cool calm and
collected in most situations
um you lose patience with people who are
not as efficient as you yeah dumb people
do annoy me
um you often end up doing things at the
last possible moment yeah that's pretty
true you've always been fascinated by uh
by the question of what if anything
happens after death death yes okay and
I'll tell you what happened to me so a
couple years ago I couldn't figure out
what religion I was so I decided to like
run all the religions down and like go
through them it's a long story but then
my dad I because I was like Dad what if
I die and I don't go to heaven like
that'd be horrible and he's like well
you wouldn't have to worry about it
because you'd be dead and ever since
then I was like you're right and I felt
like that was the best way to look at
things so now I would say I used to do
that but now ever since my dad gave me
that answer I was like oh it doesn't
really matter you'll be dead you usually
prefer to be around to be around others
than on your own oh I would agree I'm a
people person you become bored or lose
interest when the discussion gets highly
theoretical disagree I think that's a
lot of YouTube you find it easy to
empathize with a person whose
experiences are very different from
yours see okay I I feel like YouTube
might say no because I do I do humble
people on the channel however I I think
in my personal life off of YouTube I do
but you know I mean you guys might
disagree in the comments um you usually
postpone final decision making
finalizing decisions for as long as
possible yes sure I hate making
decisions you rarely second guess the
choices you have made I do second guess
naturally but my dad has taught me not
to because he says you can't change the
past so just move forward so I would say
I do still do it but I try not to after
a long and exhausting week a lively
social event is just what you need yeah
I'm pretty extroverted so I enjoy social
events I don't go to many but I'd like
to at least invite me
um you enjoy going to Art Museums okay I
normally don't but the last time I went
to one I actually liked it because I
realized there's the words next to the
art where it says the story but behind
the painting and that makes it a lot
more interesting so I'm not going to do
strongly agree but I kind of like it now
I switched my view you often have a hard
time understanding other people's
feelings see like I have this thing
where it's like I understand it but I
still think you're wrong no I I do think
I understand where people are coming
from I'm gonna do slide degree slide you
might you might find me on this
um you like to have to have a do a to-do
list for each day I should but I don't
yeah I'm gonna put it disagree I do have
to do list but they're kind of like
working ones where I'm like I'll have to
do this this it's very disorganized you
rarely feel insecure I do feel insecure
sometimes so I would say I would say
creep but not I don't it doesn't like
hold me back you know what I mean
um you avoid making phone calls uh
disagree because I like phone calls you
often spend a lot of time trying to
understand views that are different from
your own yeah that's what I do on
YouTube I would say
um in your Social Circle you're often
the one who contacts your friends and
initiates activities yeah I I well okay
I had a life before YouTube and before
YouTube I was the one to do it but ever
since I've been on YouTube oh actually
no we've had a couple I'm gonna I'm
gonna say agree I'm gonna say agree if
your plans are interrupted your top
priority is to get back on track as soon
as possible yeah I would say I always
have like a goal so if I if I can't do
something and something gets in a way
like I always want to do it so it's like
great but not strongly you are still
bothered by mistakes that you made a
long time ago
sometimes sometimes I think of stupid
things I've said
randomly and I like to say that I don't
but you know so sometimes I'd be up at
night
you rarely
contemplate the reasons for human
existence or the meaning of life
disagree I do that a lot um your
emotions control you more than you
control them okay I am a woman so your
emotions do control you but I would say
I am in control of my emotions most of
the time
um
um you take great care to not make
people look bad even if it was
completely their fault I think it would
be hard to argue that with this section
of YouTube
I don't ever want to make someone like
look bad
um however if you do say something
stupid on my show I'm not gonna help you
so I would say disagree slightly
um your work style is closer to
spontaneous bursts of energy oh yeah
that's so true when someone thinks
highly of you you wonder how long it
will take for them to feel disappointed
in you oh okay sort of but it's only
because I feel like sometimes when
people see me on the internet like they
put me on this pedestal where it's like
I'm still a person like I can't live up
to this like pedestal you've kind of
created of me so I will say like
sometimes I feel like I can't live up to
that so I could agree you would love a
job that requires you to work alone most
of the time disagree I love working with
people that's how I like talk to people
four days a week you believe that
pondering abstract philosophical
questions is a waste of time disagree
you feel more drawn to busy bustling
atmospheres than quite intimate places I
agree you know at first glance how
someone is feeling no no I don't you
often feel overwhelmed the past year I
have I've been doing a lot this year but
I kind of like being busy so I have to
agree you complete things methodically
without skipping over any steps oh no
I'm a step Skipper I'm a step Skipper
yeah I just want to do things as quick
as possible you are very intrigued by
things labeled as controversial oh no I
hate controversy
okay I'm gonna put a green you would
pass along a good opportunity if you
thought someone else needed it more if
it was a better fit for them but no I I
chase down opportunities so if I see a
good opportunity I'm gonna go for it
your stroke you struggle with deadlines
yeah I do
you feel confident that things will work
out I do I am a big believer and it'll
be fine I do get stressed sometimes so
I'm gonna say agree debater well I think
that would make sense I do debate for a
living Debaters are curious and flexible
thinkers who cannot resist an
intellectual challenge 89 yeah that's
true I knew this I took Jordan
Peterson's personality test a while ago
and he put me in the 90th percentile
extroverted I mean who who else could
talk to people four nights a week an
introvert not me are not not an
introvert that's what that's why I feel
I was built for YouTube because I could
talk to myself for an hour straight
extroverted individuals readily enjoy
groups and activities and value social
interactions they tend to be outwardly
enthusiastic and express their
excitement 66 in intuitive individuals
are very imaginative open-minded and
curious they value originality and focus
on hidden meetings and distinct
possibilities yeah to 79 thinking
thinking individuals focus on
objectivity and rationality often
dismissing emotions in favor of logic
they tend to see Effectiveness as more
important than social harmony 86 percent
prospecting prospecting individuals are
very good at improv improvising and
adapting to Opportunities they tend to
be flexible non-conformists who value
novelty above stability what is a
novelty oh yeah I am yeah
um 58 assertive assertive individuals
are self-assured even tempered and
resist resistant distressed they refuse
to worry too much and tend to be
self-confident when striving to achieve
goals okay that was interesting
quick-witted and audacious Debaters
aren't afraid to disagree with the
status quo in fact they're not afraid to
disagree with pretty much anything or
anyone few things light people let few
things light up people with this
personality type more than verbal
sparring yeah that's why I was built to
be a YouTuber and if the conversation
veers into account controversial terrain
so much better it would be a mistake
though to think of Debaters as
disagreeable disagreeable or
mean-spirited instead people with this
personality are knowledgeable and
curious with a playful sense of humor
and they can be incredibly entertaining
they often have an offbeat contrarian
idea of fun one that involves a healthy
dose of Spirited debate yeah that's true
oh my gosh because that's the one thing
like I'm I am more agreeable like I took
Jordan Peterson's personality test and
it put me in the 70 something percentile
of agreeableness so I'm more agreeable
but it's interesting being an agreeable
person that likes to disagree it's like
the opposite okay Debaters are the
ultimate doubles Advocates thriving on
the process of shredding arguments and
beliefs and letting ribbons drift in the
wind for all to see breaking the rules
follow the path of the unsafe
independent thinker and expose your
ideas to the danger of controversy
that's Thomas Watson Debaters are known
for the rebellious streak for this
personality type no belief is too sacred
to be questioned no idea is too
fundamental to be scrutinized and no
rule is too important to be broken or at
least thoroughly tested sometimes
Debaters even rebel against their own
beliefs by arguing the opposite
Viewpoint just to see how it would look
from the other side that's true as
Debaters see it most people are too
ready to do as they're told and blindly
conform to social norms pressures and
standards Debaters enjoy the mental
exercise of questioning the prevailing
mode of thought and they take a certain
pleasure in uncovering the value in
underdogs of and outliers their active
mind can't help that's how I feel I like
can't help how much I think about things
their active Minds can't help but
rethink the things that everyone else
takes for granted and push them into
clever new directions like I couldn't
stop I can't for many Debaters one of
life's greatest challenges is to
translate their wide-ranging
intellectual energy into real world
achievements and contribution that's
your I don't know what I would do if
YouTube didn't exist I would just be in
a room by my myself talking to myself
can you imagine I would go nuts
um well debater I'd probably be at like
some bar like arguing with people like
that's probably where I would be
um while Debaters personalities love to
brainstorm and think big big they tend
to avoid getting caught doing the grunt
work of implementing their ideas to some
extent this makes sense Debaters have
far too many thoughts and suggestions to
keep track of them all let alone turn
them into reality but unless Debaters
develop the willingness to identify and
actually follow through on their
priorities they may struggle to harness
their full potential the cost of
contrarianism did you tell me what that
meant earlier
oh okay okay so so he said if you
couldn't hear it he said that it's
someone that takes the other side
debater's capacity for debate is
legendary I I am goaded I am goaded but
that doesn't mean it's always helpful
but they openly question their boss in a
meeting or pick apart everything their
significant other says Debaters may
think they're being Champion champions
of logic and rationality but they also
also may be doing their chances of
success and happiness more harm than
good not every occasion calls for this
personality types contrarianism and most
people can only stand to have their
beliefs questioned and their feelings
brushed aside for so long as a result
Debaters may find that their quarrelsome
fun Burns many bridges often
inadvertently Debaters are also
respected for their Vision confidence
and knowledge and Keen sense of humor
but unless they cultivate a bit of
sensitivity they may struggle to
maintain deeper relationships or even
achieve their professional goals I have
learned this in life like if my someone
in my family I'm not going to name names
says something that I think is stupid
I've learned in life to not say that and
maybe to just keep some of the facts
that I know to myself just in the name
of getting along I won't name names
anyways many Debaters find that a more
compassionate approach is worth
exploring as they strive to build solid
relationships with time many Debaters
realize their ideal life involves other
people and that spending too much time
on winning arguments ultimately means
that robbing themselves of the support
that they need to get where they want to
be in life the good news is that people
with this personality type will never
lose their sharply non-conformist Edge
they can simply use their cognitive
flexibility to understand and explore
other people's perspective recognizing
the value of consideration and
compromise alongside logic and process
and these are the four Debaters out
Weird Al I don't know who that is but
that can't be accomplished Adam Savage I
don't know who that is I've heard of
Sarah Silverman I've heard of her Mark
Twain I like that one I've heard him and
Tom hey I want Tom Hanks that's the one
that I'm I'm gonna identify with I've
done this before and all I remember was
the thing at the bottom said Oprah I
just remember I was the same one as
Oprah but I've also gotten debater
before I've did this a while ago if you
guys like this video let me know and if
there's another personality test I
should do if we get 10 000 likes on the
video I will do another personality test
make sure you guys subscribe to the
channel as you already know we're trying
to hit a million by New Year's like the
video on your way out and we will talk
to you next time as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible